all right final Trump event from the
weekend that I want to go over Donald
Trump gave a statement of some kind the
lighting use for a while now the
lighting has been terrible on these
Trump videos the new thing now is that
the camera is out of focus
and also
um the audio is out of sync with the
video so what you hear doesn't seem to
line up with Trump's mouth very strange
speech but sadly one of Trump's main big
priorities if he were to become your
president again
is that he will put God back in schools
which is a really horrible thing to hear
so to traditional religious teachings
under my leadership we will bring back
God to our schools and our public
squares and that will happen very
quickly on day one we will begin to find
the radical zealots and marxists who
have infiltrated the Federal Department
of Education and we will have them
escorted from the building right so day
one they will find marxists of whom
there are essentially none in positions
of power anywhere
um and they will fire them I guess and
escort them out pandering to the
so-called evangelicals pandering to the
so-called Moral Majority and all of this
is It's really unclear that this is a
good idea this next clip I'm going to
play for you is Trump going hard
anti-abortion and again when you look at
public opinion it is not obvious that
the anti-abortion direction is the right
way to go we'll stand proudly in defense
of innocent life just as I did for four
very powerful strong years because every
child born and unborn is a sacred gift
from God so standard Hardline
anti-abortion language except the
country keeps moving left on that issue
and the anti-abortion push in the wake
of Roe v Wade's repeal was not a good
thing for Republicans last clip here
this one seems to be in sync which is
good better better quality at this point
in time but again Trump's spreading
anti-abortion lies I will continue to
stand strong against the extreme
late-term abortionists in the Democrat
Party who believe in abortion on demand
in the ninth month of pregnancy and even
executing babies after birth they
actually talk Beyond birth after birth
Earth executing the baby untrue of
course this has been widely debunked
there's simply no evidence of it part of
this was claimed to be out of New York
couldn't find any evidence of it part of
it was I believe Virginia they repeat it
and repeat it if you want to understand
how that claim enters the flex the
standard lexicon of abortion check out
my clip from Thursday the anatomy of
right wing propaganda and it'll tell you
how rumor becomes stated as if it were
fact at the very top of the Republican
Party insane weekend for Trump it's
going to be a crazy week for Joe Biden
as well expected to announce his
re-election we will have it all after
this break we will check in on uh where
is Ron DeSantis turns out he's not in
Florida again and much more stay with us